[Music]
NASA's Solar Dynamics Observatory
listens to the Sun
the sound that picks up is too deep for
humans to hear but if you speed up 40
days recording into a few seconds this
is what you get
it's the sound of chaos
since we can't see into the Sun its
sound is vital to scientist when a gun
fires the bullet rushes out and smashes
into air creating waves of turbulence
[Music]
when we hear the gun firing these waves
vibrate our ear drops
what we see here is sound the Sun works
the same way on a much larger scale when
we see these waves moving across what
we're looking at is when material moves
up from inside the Sun and it makes
noise it's just like ran into a surface
it's just ran into a wall and it
generates sound and we see that sound
moving all around the Sun sound waves
crashing through the plasma create
ripples and the sun's surface and all we
see are these ripples those are the
actual sound waves of the Sun and they
move around the entire Sun they move
down inside the Sun and move back up to
the surface by tracking the sound
scientists can see the invisible
they pick up sound waves smashing
against the sun's surface and resonating
throughout the solar interior revealing
a violent boiling convection zone
the Sun can be said to be ringing you
have this hot gas rising you have cool
gas falling you have all this turbulence
you have so much action going on that it
caused the Sun the ring columns of gases
rise and fall churned by heat from below
if you look at water boiling bubbles of
gas or water rising up because they're
hot and then they cool off and then they
sink back down and if you look at a pot
of boiling water that's the same
phenomena that's going on on the Sun but
with hot plasma instead of water